hola buenas tardes una extensa jornada
con fuertes cuestionamientos por parte
de senadores sobre todo demócratas y
como vimos a la senadora kamala harris
pues cuestionó fuertemente a barrett
sobre su posición frente a la ley de
cuidado en salud y la llevó a reconocer
que nunca se ha pronunciado a favor de
esta ley también aprovecho barrett para
asegurar que no está a favor del racismo
la discriminación racial en los eeuu sin
embargo evitó responder sobre si existe
o no discriminación electoral para el
día de mañana se espera una jornada
similar será el último y cuarto día de
audiencias públicas al interior del
comité judicial del senado y también el
republicano lindsey graham pues ha
citado a que se dé una votación al
interior de este comité mañana lo que
trataría básicamente de acelerar el
proceso para la votación final al
interior del pleno del senado que se
podría realizar
del mes de octubre es decir a tan solo
tres días de que se lleguen a realizar
las elecciones presidenciales en
noviembre 3 así que estos digamos serán
básicamente los mismos cuestionamientos
que veremos el día de mañana con temas
centrales como discriminación racial
acceso a cuidado en salud al igual que
otros temas relacionados con las
elecciones
diana gracias por toda la información
que tenga usted un feliz resto de tarde